there's a lot going on but what have we
learned about Jim Comey from his book
and the interviews he's done about the
book well maybe the most shocking fact
of all is how banal he is come here and
the most powerful law-enforcement agency
in America he was a central player in
the last presidential election and in
its aftermath ever since you think he'd
be impressed when he speaks even if you
don't agree with him but no Jim Comey is
as conventional as they come we know
that now his interviews sound like
Chelsea Clinton doing a Q&A with Us
Weekly Comey says his literary hero is
brace yourself Atticus Finch because
apparently couldn't think of anything
more cliched than that you couldn't
either he says he wishes Trump would
read the New York Times op-ed page he
recommended Sheryl Sandberg's lean in to
his staff at the FBI seriously and he
says he'd like to have Sandberg to a
dinner party and so on and on this is
America's top g-man or was he sounds
like every other sensitive guilt-ridden
middle-aged suburban liberal not
impressive at all maybe that's why Comey
did not hesitate before destroying any
remaining public trust in the FBI in
order to sell this book the FBI director
is not supposed to let emotion and
political considerations influence
government investigations but Comey
doesn't even hide it he admits his
behavior in the fall of 2016 may have
been colored by his desire to make
Hillary Clinton quote a legitimate
president so that settles that there's
now nobody in either party Republican or
Democrat who will ever again think the
Clinton investigation was conducted
fairly thanks Jim Comey or the Russia
investigation for that matter here's
what Comey told ABC about that watch did
you tell him that the steal does he had
been financed by his political opponents
no I didn't I didn't think I used the
term steal duskie I just talked about
additional material but did he have a
right to know that that had been
financed by his political opponents
that I don't know the answer to that it
wasn't necessary for my goal which is to
alert him that we had this information
telling the truth says Jim Comey quote
wasn't necessary for my goal apparently
it wasn't whatever else you think about
Donald Trump or his administration or
whatever you ought to be happy that that
guy Jim Comey is no longer running the
FBI Alan Dershowitz is a lawyer and
professor emeritus at Harvard Law School
as well as author of trumped up how
criminalization of political differences
in dangers democracy we spoke to him
just a minute ago
professor do the things that Comey has
said in written since he left the FBI
confirm the decision to fire him from
the FBI no it should have been done much
much earlier it should have been done on
the day of the inauguration and it
should have reflected itself in the fact
that nobody should ever have appointed
him to be head of the FBI this is a man
who was revenge driven who was prepared
to leak through a law professor at
Columbia who was prepared to disclose
confidential conversations he had with
the president-elect and the President of
the United States he's exactly the wrong
person to have headed the most important
law enforcement agency in the United
States this sends a horrible message to
FBI agents and law enforcement people
about leaking and about confidences and
about trying to keep emotion out of law
enforcement and politics out of law
enforcement to me the worst part of it
is when he both compares the president
to a mob boss which proves my point of
trumped up that you can create crimes
out of almost anything and call a mob
boss somebody who's running the
presidency of the United States and the
fact that he is willing to say on
television that it's possible that the
president was with prostitutes in a
hotel room with you know urination and
all that he's the head of the FBI he
knows the truth he has seen all the
secrets and for him to start speculating
on that kind of nonsense and rubbish and
not to disclose when he spoke to the
President as you said that this
information was paid for by a political
opponent you know I used to have
a good feeling about Comey I met him a
few times when he was in Boston I now
have only only very strong negative
feelings about him and he just enhances
the suspicion that I think so many
Americans now have of law enforcement
and we ought to be trusting law
enforcement and nobody today would trust
call me with secrets or confidences so
if he were alleging that the president
were acting like a mob boss you know
calling hits out on people committing
crimes that'd be one thing but he's in
effect criticizing the way the president
talks he's he's from Queens he does
actually sound like a mob boss sometimes
because he's from that part of the
country that's the kind of should law
enforcement officials be making comments
like this at all I mean doesn't it
detracts from the entire organization
that they purportedly represent and you
know the idea of revealing these secrets
it's is not 30 years later when he's
writing for history the way Henry
Kissinger is right and others have done
this is a gossipy revenge
make money quick get even hurt your
political opponents raised questions
about the politicizing of the Justice
Department and the FBI it's the worst
possible book at the worst possible time
for the worst possible reasons you know
we hear a lot about corrupt motives that
can't make a presidential act in write a
crime but talk about commis motives have
anybody asked him about his motives why
you wrote this book why does he feel
it's important for the American public
to hear about information that he has no
idea whether it's truthful or not it's
really scandalous and shameful and I'm
so disappointed with him so here's a lot
of friends in the FBI we know that
because the emails between them were
Fayed and now we have access to them
shouldn't it make us nervous because he
is now a political figure he's chosen to
become one what about you know Americans
who like Trump's should they be worried
about getting equal treatment from FBI
officials who are sympathetic to Jim
Comey well you know the problem is of
course it's not a problem
FBI agency human law enforcement people
are human they're are approached on
people in the FBI there and
from people they all take an oath not to
allow politics or personal views to get
in the way of their job and here we see
the former director letting his
political and personal I don't think
their partisan views there get even
views right get in the way of their of
their job and when you combine that with
the struct disclosures when you combine
that with some of the other disclosures
it may serve a good purpose because it
tells us the FBI agents are not what we
see in stereotypes in the movies they're
real human beings with passions but we
have to figure out a way of making it so
clear that these civil servants who
sacrifice their lives have to keep their
politics at home and their passions at
home and their personal views at home
and this just moves the conversation in
the wrong direction I agree and makes a
lot of people paranoid for good reason
professor thank you for coming on Razia